okay so in this video we're gonna talk
about a brief history of the theory of
evolution so let's go ahead and get
started so first of all we want to
quickly discuss what is a theory well
you know what it means in everyday
non-scientific languages is that it's
generally viewed as a hunch or a guess
to to a question for instance here we
have a group of people sitting around
maybe discussing a book and here we have
a guy who says I have a theory about the
author's intent well this man is really
about to share his interpretation of a
book you know another person in this
book group may have a very different
interpretation this man is not really
about to share a science theory but the
way he's using the word theory is kind
of causing some misleading problems when
we talk about theories and science
because in science theories are created
after years of experimentations and
years of observations there are a large
body of information created after
experiments and observations you know
for example the germ theory basically
states that many diseases are caused by
the presence and actions of
microorganisms that's not a hunch that's
not a guest
I guess germ theory is any scientific
theory created after years and years of
experimentation and observations another
example of a scientific theory would be
the cell theory you know of many parts
of the cell theory but one of the more
basic parts of the cell theory says that
cells are the basic units of life that's
not a hunch that's not a guess saying
that cells are the basic units of life
well that's been created after years of
experimentation and observation the
theory of plate tectonics that the crust
of the earth is broken into these moving
fragments again that's not a hunch
that's not a guess that is a large body
of information created after years of
experimentation and observation and so
one thing to stress is that theories are
based on testable evidence testable
observable evidence based on the natural
world
you know for reasons like this you know
we've eliminated you know
fortune-telling and you know reading
cards and predicting the future these
are not Sciences because they're not
based on testable evidence
you know palm reading again not not
science it's just not based on any
testable evidence and neither you know
reading your horoscope and the signs of
the zodiac you know people may look to
their horoscope maybe as as as guidance
or entertainment but by no means are
these scientific theories so one thing
also to mention about a theory is that
they have stood the test of time they
have withstood years of experimentation
and observation and even withstood
perhaps years of criticism and for a
science theory to still be valid that's
pretty it's a pretty strong statement in
it and it being a valid scientific
argument well here we have a person
saying I don't believe in evolution
after all it's just a theory you know
when this argument is made they are
using the word theory as if a theory is
a hunch or a guess but that's really not
the jet that's not the meaning of the
word theory in science if we apply the
definition of theory to this man
sentence he's really saying I don't
believe in evolution
after all it's a well substantiated
explanation of the natural world based
on a body effects that have been
repeatedly confirmed through
experimentation and observation when you
put it in this sense you know his
argument use it loses a lot of validity
so we need to understand what a theory
is it is by no means a hunch or a guess
so if we transition now into you know
some of the early work that was done
leading up to where we are now you know
let's look at John Baptiste de la Marck
he develops this theory called acquired
inheritance now I say it's an early
theory because today by no means is this
an acceptable scientific theory here but
at the time it was believed that traits
acquired during an organisms lifetime
could be passed on to their offspring
and as Lamarck explained acquired
inheritance you know one of the more
common examples he used was the
evolution of how giraffes got such a
long neck he argued that there were
short neck ancestors and that in their
struggle to reach the treetops in order
to get leaves for food that they began
to stretch and stretch and stretch and
stretch their necks until we see the
length that we have today and then he
argued that that extra stretchy neck
would be passed on to their offspring
every time they reproduce well I hope
you see why this is a wrong this was a
wrong theory back in its day because
today we know that traits that only
traits linked to our DNA can be passed
on to offspring and so if a if a person
would to have a shorter neck and they
were to reproduce there's a really good
chance their children would have shorter
necks it's not you're not able to
stretch your body and then pass the
extra stretchiness on to your offspring
that that's not how the process works oh
and so here's a real simple example of
acquired inheritance you know here we
have a gentleman named Jacob and Jacob
was just involved in a serious car
accident and he lost his left arm you
know he's recovered years go by and he's
what he wants to have future children
him and his wife
well his children have only one arm of
course not
but this would be acquired inheritance
if his children were born with only one
arm well that would support acquired
inheritance but knowing that his
children would be born with two arms
this would of course dispel and
discredit acquired inheritance but we
still talk acquired inheritance because
it stepped towards where we are today
and so where we are today we can trace
our understanding of evolution and
natural selection to this gentleman
Charles Darwin and what he did was he
observed that organisms have little
differences little variations based upon
their environment that they lived within
and you might know that he went on
five year boat ride and along the
journey they stopped at the Galapagos
Islands and he examined wildlife and
collected samples and specimens and
brought them back to England for further
analysis and one of the more famous
experiments centered around the finches
on the Galapagos Islands he noticed that
they had different shapes of beaks when
he went on one Island versus another
Iowa and versus another Island for
instance he noticed that the this large
beak was common on islands where there
were lots of nuts to eat so the large
beak would be helpful in cracking open
the nut so they could eat the food on
the inside and he noticed that this beak
was common on islands where there were
smaller and softer seeds and he noticed
that this beak was common to islands
that had small seeds fruits and insects
to feed upon and he noticed that this
beak was more common when two islands
that had insects and spiders so he
noticed that there were little
variations in the beaks and the-- and
that these are variations provided the
finches the birds with advantages
depending on what heaven they lived upon
and so eventually he publishes one of
the most influential science books the
Origin of Species and in this book he
outlines the process and explains how
natural selection
he believed worked and it's the process
where organisms with favorable traits
are more likely to survive and reproduce
so here's a bunch of badly drawn
giraffes and you know notice how there
are some leaves above their head well so
how did drafts get along did they
stretch themselves like Lamarck argued
no what they did was they reproduced
with one another so the giraffe
ancestors they all had little
differences just like today not every
giraffe today has exactly the same size
neck there's little variations and so
notice how some of my drafts in this
picture here have a little longer neck
than others some have a little shorter
neck than others and so those that had a
slightly longer neck had a better chance
to survive they're able to reach the
leaves
and those with the slightly shorter net
just died and so now the survivors maybe
that's a male and that's a female so now
when they reproduced and they passed
their beneficial longer neck on to the
next generation their babies and their
babies and their babies and their babies
and over time the longer neck became a
common trait simply because of natural
selection having a long neck provided an
advantage and this natural selection the
theory was first outlined in 1859 when
Darwin published the Origin of Species
one of the most if not the most
influential science book ever written
which really started us down this
journey of trying to understand how life
has evolved over the years so I want to
mention the difference between an
adaptation versus of variation well a
variation is just a difference an
inherited trait that makes one
individual different from another you
know in a group of 30 people you can see
little differences in height and hair
style and eye color and so we all have
little variations and you know when he
looked at the Galapagos Tortoises as
he's on the Galapagos Islands he
examines the tortoises and he noticed
that the shell shaped that the shell of
the tortoise differed depending upon the
environment for instance tortoises on
this island right here had a dome-shaped
shell but tortoises on this island had a
large knotch
well he noticed that that large not
allowed them to lift their heads to
greater height because these tortoises
lived on islands where there was very
little vegetation growing on the ground
so if they had to reach their heads
higher in order to feed on some of the
overhanging branches and leaves and so
this little variation of having the
knotch
would be a great example of the next
definition of an adaptation having the
knot in its shell provide
with an advantage and therefore it could
reach food it would survive better and
therefore reproduce better and pass on
this advantage so an adaptation is a
variation but one that increases or
enhances the chance of survival and so
we look at some other adaptations while
the white fur of this polar bear is an
adaptation it allows it to blend into
its snowy environment it can sneak up
better on seals and other prey so it
could capture food now here we have a
great example of an adaptation here's an
insect that resembles the appearance of
a leaf this is a wonderful adaptation if
you're the insect because it helps to
improve your chances of surviving you
know birds and reptiles reptiles may not
be is able to see you and it's not just
animals you know here's a plant
adaptation you know thorns are an
adaptation that some plants have
developed to prevent herbivores from
feeding upon them and here's a
caterpillar that resembles bird poop
this is a really funny adaptation
because again if you're a bird you
probably don't want to eat what you
think is bird poop and you're more
likely to pass this caterpillar up and
look for a food elsewhere so it's kind
of a silly fun little adaptation to
close this out today and so there you
have it a really brief introduction of
the history behind the theory of
evolution if you're in my biology class
maybe try these questions write them on
a separate sheet of paper and I'd be
happy to check your answers before a
school or after school thanks for
watching